[Music]
Kerching holds a technology degree from
Delhi University of PhD in computational
mathematics at Stanford and since his
graduate school days he has been
developing key and mathematical and
machine learning algorithms for
topological data analysis his subject
he's talking about us tonight he later
worked at Google at Texas Instruments
before co-founding the company a Yas D
and he's here tonight to talk to us
about data today and into the future
please join me in giving a big round of
applause to our speaker Gurjeet Singh
thank you again everybody hear me all
right good deal so Mike Jack alright so
the title of the talk is the shape of
data and the things to come and I am
going to be talking about using
topological data analysis to understand
large complicated data sets and what it
means and why it's important and you
will you'll see in if in a couple
minutes here why the word shape is
important I'm going to be saying that
word a whole lot in the talk before I do
that a quick introduction you know this
is this picture is actually a very good
a very good introduction to my career
overall I had graduated in the year 2008
with my PhD in computational maths
really wanted to go be a scientist
somewhere and Wired magazine the you
know came out with this magazine cover
you know in May of 2008 saying the end
of science and that was really
disheartening because that was the thing
I wanted to do
but but the interesting idea behind this
was that was the following around the
year 2000 or so DARPA and NSF who find a
lot of scientific research here in the
US realize that the way people were
doing science had changed pretty
fundamentally they realized that we were
all of a sudden in a mode where we would
create data first and ask questions
later
one good example of this phenomena was a
Human Genome Project in which you know
we collectively invested many billions
of dollars collected the first seven
human genomes in digital form and you
know we didn't really know exactly what
science would come out of it lots and
lots of great science came out of it but
we didn't quite know exactly what would
come out of it and the way we got
science out of that out of that project
was essentially by having collected the
data and then looking into it and so
DARPA and NSF realized that all of a
sudden our ability to collect data was
outstripping our ability to ask
interesting questions off the data and
so they started investing in fundamental
maths their blue sky idea back in the
year 2000 was that computers keep
getting cheaper there must be a way in
which we can build hardware and software
systems that will allow scientists to do
more science from the data so the idea
behind this wired story was you know now
all of a sudden we we will have access
to algorithms who will be able to which
will be able to sift through data and
you know sort of get us more science and
we might otherwise have gotten so the
idea kind of made sense and the way we
approached it since we were one of the
groups that they funded at Stanford to
do this science was we used an very old
area of math called topology which I'll
explain in a minute here to essentially
look through very many large number of
disciplines and find new interesting
findings in them we published in areas
as diverse as protein folding and cancer
research and image compression and
econometrics and so DARPA basically
gently asked us to commercialize the
research and that's why we started the
company asthey and that's pretty much
all I say about a asthey so for the rest
of the talk here are the four things I
want to do I want to talk about
introduce the notion of
apology and topological data analysis I
then want to give you a bunch of
real-life examples of what is possible
with this technology then I want to
basically take this talk into this idea
of explain ability in AI I believe that
a lot of our lives today are run by
algorithmic systems that most people
don't really understand even the
creators don't really quite understand
and I believe that topological data
analysis is a good way for us to get a
handle on explain ability of AI
algorithms even when the algorithms
themselves are opaque to the technique
and then finally I just want to talk
about the future of what you could do
with what could happen with topological
data analysis and with topology at large
so that's what I'm gonna do okay so the
first thing is I want to motivate an
idea in machine learning today which is
called unsupervised machine learning and
that will allow me to introduce the idea
of topology to you so let's think about
how we learn from data today imagine
that you you know you work at a lab you
know maybe you're a genomics researcher
and you're collecting gene expression
data from a bunch of cancer patients or
maybe you are at a bank and you have to
construct a stress test model you're
being given a large excel file and then
you have to learn some stuff from that
data the way it works today is you start
with a smart person and typically this
is a smart person who's you know stayed
in University maybe done a masters or
PhD you know unlike maybe a Zuckerberg
or Bill Gates who dropped out so this is
a person who stayed in school this smart
person comes up with questions or
guesses or hypotheses all right so they
might say okay maybe this is this is a
question and the data that I might go
ask they can then convert it into code
of some sort and I'm using the term code
very liberally here it I don't mean any
specific technology or they could use
what's known as business intelligence
software cool locally you know where you
can use the user interface to pose
questions for you you run those against
database see the results back and then
maybe you write maybe you aren't and in
general in the software industry we have
paid a lot of attention on the
two bits on the right the databases and
the BI systems we have tried to make
databases bigger faster and cheaper so
that the cost of asking a question can
be as low as possible and the second
thing that we have done from a software
perspective is we've tried to
democratize access to data so we have
great business intelligence software
today and that you know relatively
easily allows you to ask questions of
complicated datasets even Excel is a
very good piece of software to allow you
to do that and this has been a great
advance one of the major problems in
this this method overall is that it's a
guess and verify method you have to
hazard a guess and then the software
allows you to verify whether your guess
was correct or not and the issue with
that is that you know in the past when
data was simpler making guesses was
something that we could do today making
guesses is art is something that's
pretty much entirely out of the domain
of people when the data is more
complicated and in fact in this process
with complicated data the only time
you'll learn something is when you
hazard a guess and the software comes
back and tells you that there is no
support for your gas that you learnt
nothing then you know that your guess
was incorrect if there is some support
for your hypothesis you don't really
know whether you were whether your
hypothesis was complete or not
so the completeness of your questions is
actually a huge problem and you wouldn't
know so that is kind of a motivation of
an area of machine learning called
unsupervised machine learning where you
expose large complicated data sets to a
machine learning system and the machine
learning system learns something about
it and helps you understand it and this
also allows me to very quickly introduce
this notion of topology to you so now
I'm going to ask one math question so I
am warning everybody about that so to
introduce a math question this is a map
of the city of Konigsberg
it's now in Russia and this this there's
a river that runs through this city it's
called that it's the name of the river
is Fraggle River Fraggle and the way the
city is set up is that there is an
island in the middle the river kind of
flows around the island and then it
Forks into two pieces right so in the
year 1700 or of there about 1730
actually there wasn't a whole lot going
on so people were generally looking for
interesting dinner conversations one
interesting dinner conversation was
could you cross the entirety of the
could you go through the entirety of the
city of königsberg having crossed every
bridge only once okay so that was a
dinner conversation again without making
any statements about people's lives back
then that's what they had going on and
it was actually a vexing problem you
know people people for that about a
decade or so tried to get to an answer
to this problem
and they couldn't okay so here's the
math question how might you and I take 3
guesses how might you attempt to answer
this question what would you do three
guesses graphs very good so some
background there that's great
back then people didn't know graph
theory right so sorry
permutation combination ok that's also
also a good answer what what else might
you do trial in a great perfect and
that's what people did almost all the
time one of the things that people tried
was they basically said let me measure
the length of each bridge let me see
what is the exact kind of the coastline
and let me try and you know figure out
how long will I have to travel right all
of these things that were geographical
in nature that you could very easily see
from a map people started measuring
those things and and they couldn't solve
it it took about a decade or so and
there was a very very the most famous
mathematician arguably Leonard Euler who
eventually solved this problem and what
he realized that there was a lot of
extraneous
detail in this problem like the length
of the bridges doesn't really matter
right he realized that lots of lots of
lots and lots of these things were kind
of irrelevant to actually solving this
problem so he realized that the thing
that matters is that there are these
four land masses that are colored in
various colors here and they are
connected to each other via these
bridges and so as you suggested he
basically turned it into a graph problem
he said here's a graph and a B C and D
are the four land masses and the lines
between a B C and D represent the
bridges the bridges that connect the
connect the various land masses and very
simply he realized that there are three
edges that connect every node and so
what that means is that if you have to
cross every bridge only once you know
then there have to be there has to be an
even number of edges two edges in
particular and so since there are three
edges to every node it is simply
impossible for somebody to actually
cross the cross every bridge only once
while traversing the city so this was a
key insight and he then started
developing the area of topology and in
graph theory and under study they're off
and the key thing about topology is that
it's a study of holes and I will
describe that in a in a couple minutes
here as well so I was asked e
realization that whenever you're trying
to study a problem try and throw away a
lot of the extraneous detail and try to
focus try to reduce the problem to sort
of the essential detail in it while
maintaining the essential complexity so
let me take the example a little further
now to modern times when we actually
have more data sets and let me give you
some intuition behind topology here are
these on the screen I have these four
shapes and I'll give you a quick story
about each one of these shapes very
quickly and then I'll explain an aspect
of machine learning behind these shapes
the first shape is very simply a line so
for example you know if imagine
depressingly somewhat if you're trying
to buy a house in the Bay Area and you
make a plot of the price of the house
versus a square footage you know you
will see a linear relationship and and
in in machine learning this is called a
regression problem
where imagine if somebody said I want
you to predict the house price I'll give
you the square footage you know you
might draw a line through the set of
points that you've collected and and
that might give you some sense for how
much you will end up paying for the
house and obviously you only decide you
can't pay for it but nonetheless that's
the process we'll go through so I want
to give you some insight into how does
this machine learning process work what
does regression do the regression
assumes that your data looks like a line
or a plane and then it tries to find the
best line or plane that looks like your
data okay so keep that verbiage in mind
another another very another common
problem that we solve in many different
contexts in business or in science is
called clustering we're given a bunch of
data and you're trying to determine are
there self-similar parts of the data so
for example if you have collected data
about let's say a lot of patients who
have diabetes type 2 diabetes let's say
you might want to know are all two type
2 diabetes patients similar or are there
multiple types of type 2 diabetes
patients so you might attempt to solve
it via clustering problem and the way
clustering works is again very similar
to regression in that you assume that
your data breaks up into multiple pieces
and then you try and find the best
decomposition of your data into that
many number of pieces it's a similar to
regression you assume a particular shape
and then you try and look for that shape
in your data the third example is a loop
imagine that you are an economist and
for every year you you know figure out
the interest rate of the fed and the
growth rate of the economy and these are
your two axes and you put a dot for
every year that you collect the data you
will notice that the data evolve Xin
these cyclic patterns where when the
interest rates are low economies grow
and then eventually when the economies
have grown too much the interest rates
are tightened and the economy start to
shrink again again we are in topsy-turvy
world these days so no bearing to real
world these days apparently but
nonetheless that's what you would see in
there in your data I come back to that
picture in a second look at the force
picture imagine that you are let's say
flying from San Francisco to New York
and
you stick two sensors on the plane you
measure the amount of lift that the
plane is experiences experiencing versus
the drag that the plane is experiencing
and when you plot the picture on the
screen you know you will see a picture
like this fourth picture on the screen
here which is that for the most of the
flight you will be in the middle part of
the region where lift and drag change a
little but not a whole lot but there's a
few anomalous things that happen you
take off at some point you land at some
point and you might go into turbulence
and come back at some point and those
are the three flares that you see here
okay now with this background I want to
make two points the first point is that
the shape of the data actually contains
a lot of information about it if you
knew the shape of the data you know you
wouldn't have to ask many questions
about it going in the second is we have
great algorithms called regression and
clustering that solve the first two
problems but we don't have an algorithm
called loop detect or flair detect and
in fact the category of shapes that you
actually see exhibited in real datasets
is so vast that it's kind of pointless
to come up with a prototypical shape
first and then look for the shape in the
data and so that is kind of the
motivation behind using topology to
understand the shape of the data because
the shape of the data is meaningful
everybody with me thus far yeah alright
then so for people this is a I'll go
through this slide very quickly this is
for people who might be slightly more
technical in the machine learning space
but I just wanted to give you a sense of
sort of how this interacts with machine
learning or how its dependent on machine
learning so what you see in this picture
there are three data sets every row
represents a data set so the first data
set are these kind of two clasping
clasping points you know half the points
are blue and the other half are red this
the shape in the middle has blue points
in the middle and then there's the
circle that of red points at envelope
set and then the third shape is
basically two clusters red points here
and blue points here kind of like
politics I guess
so and what you see in every column
thereafter is a particular machine
learning algorithm trying to
discriminate between the blue points and
the red points okay so you see the
decision surface of these machine
learning algorithms the exact names of
these algorithms aren't important so
don't worry about those what's important
here is that you can see two things the
first thing is that data has shape as
you can see immediately in this toy
example the second thing you can also
see is that every algorithm also has a
shape so for example if you look at the
second column which is the first colored
sort of picture with the bands you will
notice that no matter what the shape of
the data is the algorithm always has
this linear structure where it will find
a line and then it will discriminate
away from it if you look at the second
from the last column you will see that
this algorithm has a shape which is that
it wants to discriminate data into boxes
so it wants to find access aligned boxes
that have various opacities and so the
key realization here is that data has
shape and algorithms also have shape the
algorithms that we use currently in
machine learning so it is really
important for us if you are if you're
going to have a hope to understand
what's going on in these algorithms and
how they make decisions it's really
important for us to understand how these
two things are linked together how the
algorithms work together with the shape
of the data and when will they make
errors and what kind of errors will they
make everybody with me thus far so just
quick summary and then I'll switch into
examples which will be a lot more fun
topological data analysis is basically
is a formalization using this old area
of math called topology that allows us
to study shape shape of data shape of
algorithms shape of decision surfaces
for people who are slightly more
technical in the audience it allows us
to merge together the results of various
other algorithms in a coherent way that
you can learn from it together
and the final point that's the most
interesting point is that it's a
compressed representation it compresses
the data and compression is really
important you know because when people
talk about big datasets and how
today's big data sets are actually kind
of useless you want datasets that are as
small as possible you want to eliminate
complexity that's meaningless right so
if you go back to the thing that I said
about the map you know there's a lot of
complexity in that map the exact shape
of the coast is kind of irrelevant so
there are many many details in data that
are irrelevant and it's actually very
useful to understand the essential
complexity of the data so compression is
a very key part of all sorts of machine
learning and in particular topological
data analysis is kind of based on
outputting a compressed representation
and it also happens to be visualizable
which is which is sort of very very very
useful ok make sense all right let's
move on to examples the first so the way
I'm doing these examples is I am
basically picking three examples from
biology because I think everybody most
people can relate to it in you know a
lot more easily and then as vary in very
one very quick slide give you sort of a
couple of examples in other domains like
in financial services and banks and so
on ok so the first example this is in
type 2 diabetes so this was done in
collaboration with Mount Sinai in New
York with with the Dudley Lab and what
they did is that they ran a very
interesting experiment they went through
10,000 people who had type 2 diabetes
and they collected data from the 10,000
people which was their clinical record
data and also their genetic data the
particular type of genetic data that
they collected here is called single
nucleotide polymorphisms so imagine an
Excel spreadsheet where every row is a
patient and there are a million columns
where you're basically probing their
genome in a million places and you're
noting the alphabet that you find in
those particular million P places and
then you also have a about 100 or so
columns which are their clinical
information so things like their weight
their BMI do they have retinopathy do
they have liver disease do they have
kidney disease things like that and now
obviously now as you're imagining this
Excel spreadsheet you know you have a
million
and a few hundred columns and you want
to study this data of course you can't
ask questions anymore because it doesn't
make sense to say you know find is it
the case that people who have a
polymorphism in position number 679 and
51 also have retinopathy right these
questions are meaningless there's just
way too many of these questions that you
might end up asking so they ran the data
through this topological data analysis
system and it created a map visually
that looks like this this image behind
me and they discovered that there's
actually three distinct types of type-2
diabetes that are genetically distinct
and one of them was basically called the
type-2 diabetes complication category
people who had high BMI and diabetic
retinopathy the second type was
potentially caused due to cancer and the
third was the most common type which is
a subtype 3 which is typically typical
of heart disease and metabolic syndrome
now the key point here is that you know
they discovered all of this using the
date using using the software but you
know we are now in an age where the
world's best scientists need this kind
of software to learn from an analyze a
data it is no longer feasible to ask
questions one after the other and expect
to find interesting things in your data
the second example is from breast cancer
it's actually one of my favorite
datasets to talk about this was one of
the papers I published during my PhD and
the reason why it's my one of my
favorite data has to talk about is it's
a very old dataset this was the first
data set ever collected about the gene
expression of breast cancer tumors so
this was collected by the Karolinska
Institute and it's called nki dataset
and for every tumor that they excised
they measured the activity of 23,000
genes and for every one of those
patients and tumor samples they also
measured some clinical variables so for
example did they survive five years out
did the cancer metastasized did they
have to have a mastectomy or a lymph
acta me and so on and
you know the data set by the time it
came to me had been studied to death we
threw it into the software and we saw
this Y shape and in this Y shape from a
network perspective the structure is
that every little node contains a group
of patients who are similar to each
other across all of their genetic data
not not the clinical data and two nodes
are connected if they share some
patients and in the software you could
color it by various things so for
example in this case I've colored it by
the probability of mortality five years
out the red means almost certain you
know bad prognosis for those patients
blue means that there is a higher
probability they'll survive five years
out now in breast cancer literature one
of the things that's very well known and
understood and well studied is the
behavior of a particular gene or a
particular hormone called estrogen
receptor when the estrogen receptor
levels are high it's generally X the
prognosis is generally not great and so
what happened in this software is as
soon as we put in the put the data into
the software we discovered this Y
structure we colored by mortality and we
saw this group of patients which are
circled here who had highest region
receptor levels but they all survived
and it's a relatively small part of the
data it's maybe only about 5% of the
patients but we replicated it across
many many different datasets and we're
always able to find this signature and
now there is actually a test that you
can do for it and so if there's a
differential procedure that's prescribed
to these patients so that's the reason
why it's one of my favorite datasets to
talk about but it's also an example of
why the shape of the data illuminated
this thing that otherwise would have
gone unnoticed all right third example
this is done in collaboration with the
Schneider lab at Stanford and so David
Schneider he he's asking a very
interesting question he's basically
looking at one patient at a time and
he's trying to see the arc of a disease
so for example somebody gets malaria and
you know for the entirety of their stay
at the hospital
you know he'll collect their their blood
samples
and measures their their proteome in the
blood proteome essentially measures a
bunch of proteins in the blood and he
the question he wants to answer is what
is the disease trajectory in what cases
does the disease reject rego into a bad
state in what cases does a disease
trajectory come back into a healthy
state now from a topological perspective
one thing you'll notice is that all of
the examples I'm showing you here are
full loops and so what that tells us is
that all these patients started from a
healthy state and came back to a healthy
state so so that's why it's a full loop
they were also example in his paper
where they could predict sort of some
offshoots of the of the circle where
people did not return to healthy states
and so this was actually really
insightful for them to actually place a
patient in a part of the loop and say
you know I believe that you are 60%
through the cycle so for the first time
we can actually give a measure to the
percentage completion of the disease and
whether you are actually going to
recover or if you're not going to
recover then you know maybe maybe the
protocol needs to change or maybe we
have a secondary infection that he needs
to get treated that you need to get
treated for and so that was really
insightful make sense all right so now
I'll switch gears and I'll talk about
some examples out of out of biology so
the the first example is from financial
services one of the major pain points in
our current economic system is money
laundering where we lose we lose
billions upon billions of dollars every
year to money that's been laundered and
has been converted into illegal money
now banks suffer the brunt of this which
means that banks are almost being asked
by regulators to become law enforcement
so banks are supposed to monitor every
transaction and if they feel that a
transaction has suspicious not only are
they supposed to stop it
stop the transaction itself they are
supposed to report it to the regulators
within 72 hours and so it's a hugely
expensive process for the banks an
average Bank such as an HSBC or a JP
Morgan
you know spends about close to 700
million dollars a year in this
compliance process and now the
statistics of the process are also very
complicated so what happens is you have
a team of investigators investigators
oftentimes anywhere from five to ten
thousand people who are investigating
these transactions and 99% of the times
their investigations do not result in a
suspicious activity report so 99% of the
work of 5,000 people you very well might
not have done and achieve the same risk
to the bank so this application
essentially utilizes a behavioral
profile of customers or it says is that
I'm going to study every customer based
on the transactions that I have seen
from that customer over the past year
and a half or two years and based on
that I'm going to assign a risk to every
customer and based on based on the risk
classification of the customer I'm going
to either investigate at a higher level
or lower level this system basically
reduces their investigative volume by
about 26 percent while ensuring that
nothing that was suspicious in the past
stops being suspicious and discovering
new types of money laundering that they
would have missed otherwise so that's
the first example the second example is
in clinical variation management our
health care system in the u.s. is not
amazing and so there are many side
effects of this one side effect is that
if you go to a hospital system and you
know let's say you are there for a knee
surgery and you go to the hospital
system and say okay how much is it going
to cost how long am I going to be here
they basically can't answer these
questions in any level of detail that a
smart person or a regular person these
days would like and you know the
question is why why is it the case why
are they why can't they just find these
numbers why is it difficult the problem
is that there is next to no
standardization in health care now some
of it is expected you know everybody is
unique so you can't have a cookie cutter
sort of procedure for everybody but the
amount of standardization and healthcare
is so low that every patient is actually
treated uniquely so what this
application does
that it hooks into their electronic
medical record systems and it hooks into
their financial system the hospital's
financial systems and it tries to
determine the good variation in care
that's being offered to patients for
every procedure and the bad variation
that's being offered to patients for
every procedure and it helps physicians
look at that data helps them understand
the data and helps them adopt discover
and Rob best practices and again this is
a category where you know for example if
you go for a knee surgery the number of
events that happen to you are close to
5,000 and these are all the way from
nursing orders to dietary orders to the
actual implant to the post-op procedure
to the follow-ups and so on but the
variation is humongous
so the 5000 events that happened to me
or that matter that might happen to
somebody else are so different that it's
actually a very very difficult problem
to find the standardized some
standardization in sort of how the care
will progress the anecdote here is that
you know one of the one of the latest
people to try this is a small community
hospital system in Florida called
Flagler who basically determined that
for patients suffering with pneumonia
and they they have an aging population
that they serve there for the patient
suffering in pneumonia they were able to
lower their length of stay in the
hospital by about a day and lower the
cost of a per patient per encounter by a
thousand dollars which at their scale is
worth millions of dollars and obviously
it delivers better care to many of those
patients third example cybersecurity
again we you know not a day go not a day
goes by when you you know don't read a
report in the Wall Street Journal
something about a hack or or something
of that sort our general response to
cybersecurity in the tech industry has
been firewalls which is to say we are
going to stop bad people from coming
into the network but once somebody is in
the network it's actually relatively
hard for somebody to figure out how'd
they get in and what should we do now so
what this application does is that it
does a novel form of anomaly detection
where it tries to detect when an
internal employee is being impersonated
by an external actor
and so its first application in its
first application at a large telecom
company essentially had them discover 15
criminals who are already hiding in
their system from amongst 11 and a half
million accounts and finding 15 out of
an eleven and a half million of anything
is generally generally a hard thing to
do a final example stress testing this
is also in financial services so after
the 2008 financial crisis which was
obviously a very difficult and bad event
the the Fed essentially mandated that
every bank or every fiduciary
institution which carries cash accounts
has to predict what will happen to their
accounts in the event of a downturn
how will they how will the cash react
and will they have enough to cover their
reserves but they have enough cash to
carry the risk that they are carrying on
their books one particular bank Citibank
kind of failed this process three years
in a row their then CEO got fired you
know because of this because of this
process a new CEO came in also failed
once so that didn't help clearly in that
case now the question is why do they
keep you know why is it that rises that
they are not able to do this what was
the problem they have all the data it's
all internal they have a few hundred
people building these models so it's not
a lack of people they have all the
software that mankind has ever created
to solve this problem and they have the
will to solve it it's not lost on them
that their market cap just soar dropped
by thirteen billion dollars and they
lost you know when they were not able to
pass the test it turns out that the
problem is actually finding the right
hypotheses actually figuring out which
are the key variables that affect your
business that you can stand behind and
that you can convince the regulator you
understand your business well and so
again this application helps these banks
you know get through this stress test
process very more dramatically than they
might have otherwise make sense all
right so let me shift gears and talk
about explain ability the reason I am
passionate about explain ability is
because as as a creator of these kinds
of AI systems you know
there is a responsibility that that we
have in in sort of figuring out when
they might go wrong a lot of our lives
today are governed by these narrow AI
systems that already worked quite well
in the narrow domain in which they are
in which they are built but how do we
govern them and I think that's an
important problem for our age that we
need to try and solve so I believe there
are these five interesting questions
that we have to begin to answer which is
is the input data biased so if the input
to a machine learning system is biased
or if it's incorrect or if it has a
blind spot in a certain area how do we
detect it and how do we fix it
the second is is the model making
systematic errors so is it the case that
you know whenever it's raining outside
the models just showing me weird news on
Google News and that doesn't happen but
you know it's the kind of thing you
would like to know how certain are we
about the model in the regime of the
input data so I have a model for example
a mortgage model at a bank and it's
making decisions but a new type of
lender has started applying for my model
maybe because there's an economic shift
or a social shift is the old model is
not valid anymore how how do I know that
is actually making good calls or not can
you explain the logic behind the model
so generally the answer is no so but
then what can you do what's the next
best thing you can do and how do we
detect regimes we're missing data and
then how do we gather it so let me give
you a few examples of these these
problems the first one is the input data
biased this is a generally pretty
depressing study the data is available
on CDC and so what this what this data
is you know for every hospital visit
when somebody goes into triage in the ER
you know there is a model that's done to
figure out how cute is this should we
look at it right away or can they wait
and so that's called a triage model and
what you see is on top the same network
of the same data it's colored by the
predicted mortality of the model and at
the bottom it's colored by the actual
mortality that you see so you will see a
couple of things in this the first thing
that you can see
is that generally speaking the model
does a fine enough job right generally
speaking you see more band mortality
towards the right
generally the model is is making those
predictions it's fine the second thing
that you will notice is that the model
is very optimistic right the model is
very regular and very optimistic there
are lots of places here that are
certainly at the bottom yellowish that
the model is yeah it's it's blue it's
happy it's fine
the one particular area that I want to
point out is is circled up here which is
the model says it's totally fine no
problem and those people all end up
basically not surviving the ER
experience so the question is why it
turned out that these people were
delirious enough that they couldn't
answer a few questions on the survey so
missing data was causing this problem in
the model right so this is an example of
how do we detect bias in the input data
to the models where we can then go
hopefully correct it either in some
human way or process or in some
systematic way second example is the
model making systematic errors this is
an example from from a fighter jet if
you've read the news recently the f30
and f-16 programs aren't doing amazingly
well and one of the major reasons is
that a lot of pilots in these systems
are having hypoxia events and what that
means is when they're flying the plane
all of a sudden they're they become
unconscious and when they you know when
they eventually land it turns out that
they had a severe lack of oxygen for a
small amount of time with led them to
becoming unconscious now obviously this
is not lost on anybody not on Lockheed
not on Boeing not on the Air Force
itself so the question is you know what
are they doing about it
to their credit they've installed lots
and lots and lots of sensors in the
plane so in fact a plane today collects
about a terabyte of data every minute
from all these sensors right now again
the obvious problem when you collect a
lot of data is how do you know when you
know how do you know that
when you know the data is actually
pointing to something useful or not and
similar to the compliance thing that I
talked about earlier in this case 99% of
those cases are just false alerts they
are alerts that happen where you alert
on every single variable so for example
the thrust of the plane is - I'm making
this up but the thrust of the plane is
too high so you're alerting on it but
it's not really meaningful the things
that lead to these weird events are
combinations of events that you have to
find so in this example you know you
discover the systematic errors of the
false alarm model is making and then you
expose it to through a user experience
that usable by a domain expert so that a
domain expert you know who wants to get
to the root cause is able to figure out
the root cause and fix the problem I
wrote cause so this is the example in
figuring out systematic errors the third
is how certain are we about the model in
the input regime of the data so we've
created a model and so this case this is
a financial stress test model and we
want to figure out which variables are
the most important I'm just speeding up
a little bit just looking at the time
here so I'll go quickly through this but
again the case here is that for every
time you get an input to the model you
can place it on the model that you've
created in the back end this topological
map and you can figure out is it a is it
and is it a region of high certainty or
not so at least you can attach estimates
to every prediction that you make
individually and say that hey if I'm
recommending this news article to
somebody you know what is my estimate
that I will be correct in this
prediction so I think it's a really
important ability for models to have to
do that
finally like the second last example
here is how do we explain the logic
behind the model so this is a picture of
Alvin four people in the machine
learning community this was the first
time we built kind of a self-driving
machine and it worked pretty well
actually right it worked amazingly well
for the time it had a camera system and
a self drive system and all that it
turned out that you know they built this
over the fall they built it really
really quickly and when they tested it
on the first day of summer it didn't
work so the question was why why is it
not working and it turned out that the
model had learned too
to to basically see the sky as being
gray so if the sky was blue the model is
like what what just happened you know I
don't know what to do anymore so today
in our image detection systems we run
very more complicated models so this is
a this is a deep learning model for
people who have seen the news recently
deep learning is making all sorts of
waves and perception problems things
like image classification you know text
and sound and so on and in all these
perception problems you know when you
learn these models they are essentially
huge arrays of numbers that's what a
model is these days like these deep
learning models and they require a large
amount of data to train and there is no
easy explanation you know so if somebody
said why did this model do this what am
I going to say will I say that the
computer knows how to multiply numbers
correctly so hence it must be correct
because that's the best I can say today
is the model learnt these numbers and
the computer knows how to multiply so
you know that's it we think there's a
better way so this is an example very
use topological data analysis to
introspect into the model what you do is
you take those large weight matrices
that you've learnt you throw it into the
topological data analysis framework and
it helps you figure out what are the
base patterns of the model has learnt
and how are they connected to each other
in fact it also allows you to speed up
the training so there's a problem in
machine learning called sample
efficiency how much data do you need to
train a model so that at you so that you
like its result sample efficiency is a
huge problem and so topological data
analysis at least in this perception
visual problem allows you to speed up
your training time by about 4x by giving
it some topological information about
about the base underlying data yeah
finally how do we okay let me skip that
generally speaking there are two things
about the future that I like to say the
first thing is AI systems of the future
what should we expect smart AI systems
of the future to do and I believe these
five abilities are fundamentally
important the first is to discover which
is when exposed to large complex data
these AI systems have to be able to come
up with hypotheses from the data without
a human being talent telling it exactly
what to do
the second is to make predictions I
think we do a pretty good job and we are
continuing to do this better and better
the third is to justify which is to
explain the logic behind the model and
why it makes the decision it makes the
fourth is to act which is that we must
build these systems for domain experts
if you are going to require an army of
data scientists to do any of this you
know then the common man has no hope of
actually being able to use these
effectively you know like I said even
the best scientists in the world you
know need these kinds of systems today
so it's very useful - very important to
build contextual user experiences for
them and finally to learn which is as
data evolves the models have to
understand how they are feeling and
evolve so that's the final bit okay now
things to come now this is not about
topological data analysis but this is
about topology in general and why it's
useful and why you should care the 2016
Nobel Prize was awarded to tool s
Haldane
and cost relates for topological phases
of matter essentially they studied very
small films of atoms and molecules at
very very cold temperatures and there
were some interesting quantum effects
that nobody had explained before that
they were able to explain and it has led
to a huge amount of research in the area
of topological materials some of the
things that we have already benefited
from better hard drives so for example
the data density on hard disk today is
orders of magnitude higher than before
because of these kinds of topological
discoveries and we are able to engineer
topological domains on the platter
itself to increase its capacity
the second is insulators so there is an
interesting topological effect where you
can build wires which are super thin
which can conduct charge and insulate at
the same time where the core of the wire
can start conducting charge but the
edges of the wire are insulators so it's
a very exotic exotic way of building
these things but these might be
commonplace by the time my kids grow up
superconductors a lot of the recent
research in superconductors has been
made possible to do topological
properties at the quantum scale and
finally in computing cube there's
quantum computing is a new frontier in
in in computing and one of the major
problems in quantum computing is
essentially the stability of the bits so
topological properties of quantum
materials have a chance of actually
being able to make more stable qubits
where we will be able to read read data
from them with a higher probability of
success than before just because
topologically we can lock the data in so
to speak all right that's that's what I
had happy to answer question I'm sorry I
went a little bit over ask the kind of
goofy question somebody else who is also
not a math major might also be afraid to
ask so I'm gonna do a couple of those in
here and while you were thinking of your
much better questions that you want to
ask and we have somebody on our staff
has the mic so what you're gonna want to
do if you want to ask a question get
that gentleman's attention he will hand
you the mic and then we'll call them so
don't don't worry about letting us know
but look out for for the fella back
there have a seat thank you so much that
was fantastic so I'm gonna ask one of
these questions right now that I bet I'm
not the only one that that's going so
probably a lot of us in this room the
only version of topology that we are
aware of is topological maps and I'm not
thinking very complexly about it was
like oh it's the height so so so can you
connect that concert is this is this the
correct application of topology how what
how do we better understand topology
through being experts about topological
map so the ball trophy and topology are
different ah topography is my job I
smile right but there is there is a
connection there is a connection there
okay it actually turns out that to that
there are certain sorts of topological
constructions that require that require
these functions such as the height
function so in topography the way we do
topography is we have one function which
is the height and we look at the
contours of the height wherever the
height is stable we draw contour
that's our topography works topology you
basically extend the idea to too many
different types of functions there are
limitations on the types of functions
but there are many many cases where you
can build these kinds of functions one
example of this being useful is the
example that I gave of our stress
testing in in banks that actually uses
one such function that we call
eccentricity mapping and it turns out
that that function we just developed in
in biology many many years ago ended up
being super useful for understanding
these financial kinds of datasets and
nobody would have thought about it so in
a way I'll probably do this wrong too
but but it's it's in a way almost like
2d versus 3d is it like it's one
demented a tough tough tough
topography is a single dimension height
and the others are that yes okay yeah
okay fantastic
thank you you did very well on that do
make sure to hold your mic yep um so
everyone can hear you and we want to
thank by the way quick shout-out to our
long now members who are watching or
listening from home
thanks guys we're really glad you're
paying attention and another great
reason to join long now so let's go back
to to the beginning the history here
what was the the German gentleman's name
who Leonard Euler okay how do you spell
it boiler EU and ER now were there any
precedence whatsoever from what was I
mean did is that kind of made out of
whole cloth to solve this bridge problem
or is yes honor order was a was one of
the best mathematicians ever to have
existed so yeah I think he just made
stuff up in general and that's almost
you know that's basically the reason why
the freedoms medal which is kind of the
Nobel Prize of mathematics is typically
you know earned by very very young
mathematicians is you got to make stuff
up and so and and we're gonna get to
Italian questions in a second here but
as your and you touched on and so it's
so interesting the applications across
different industries at different
problems but I'm I'm curious is I mean
in a way things kind of we can extract
data about all these different things
and the data itself in its form may look
very similar when you're looking at it
with this kind of analysis do you see
sort of similar shapes as it were across
different areas is is the health data
and the financial data are there you
know I mean I it's funny I think one
thing I think about in this area is is
people that have done like stock price
analyses that have different shapes that
they respond to in their bidding and so
forth right so do it are the insights
that are seen in say some of this health
data around the disease useful in some
way or are there almost archetypes that
are caught that are that are applicable
to a financial set of data or something
so I think slightly real not exactly but
slightly related is this notion of
algorithmic serendipity which is
something that we've noticed over and
over and over again so one of the ways
in which you know we architected our
software was to basically say you know
we have this huge library of machine
learning functions all sorts uper wise
unsupervised semi-supervised and so on
and we would basically from a software
perspective run all of them on as much
data as we possibly could for any given
problem and over and over and over again
we've realized algorithms that were
developed in one area ended up being
useful in another area and people in for
example financial services never studied
algorithms in biology and you know they
had no reason to their textbooks don't
mention them yeah but it turns out that
they are this algorithmic serendipity is
actually very very beneficial it's kind
of mana from heaven you don't have to do
anything you put it in throw it into the
blender it comes out and being useful I
think we have a question from the
audience back there please hi hi thanks
so much for the talk was terrific
asking this question from a cognitive
science point of view hmm so I know that
you're not trying to model human
cognition or human learning but it does
strike me that we know some things about
human learning particularly in the areas
of vision and language yeah that are
illustrative and offers some
possibilities of improving a merely
statistical or stochastic analysis of
outch to find anything is out so
envision for example as you know we have
to solve the inverse problem we have
your computer three-dimensional
representation from the two-dimensional
informational array and the consensus
among vision scientists I mean they the
consensus is there have to be some kinds
of innate constraints on hypotheses that
get considered there's variation about
how they think those hypotheses are
embodied in the brain but it strikes me
that some of these some of these issues
might be more fruitfully approached you
might get a better learning model if you
could somehow incorporate the analog of
constraints is there any interest in
doing that sort of incorporation yes I
love that question thank you for asking
it so there are two studies that we read
at Stanford that I think are
illustrative of this you know in biology
there are a lot of cognition studies are
done on mouse models so and on mouse
models so there were two studies that we
did in collaboration with UCSF where we
had a Utah array it's called it's
basically you implanted in the brain of
a mouse and then you collect data from
their brain while they are doing various
tasks so one study which we did was
essentially on the vision tasks where we
were showing them imagine imagine a
black and white screen where you're
cycling the black and white so imagine a
black bar that's moving down the screen
right and we collected that data from
the from the brain of the mouse and we
when we ran analyze the data it actually
turned out that the topology of those
signals replicated the topology of the
animation that was running the animation
was running in a loop right the bars are
moving down and then go up and then move
down in the coop and
and you could see in the data that we
collected and we analyzed this way that
you could see a loop in the in the data
that we collected from the brain signals
as well so in other words the topology
of information representation in the
brain mimicked the topology of the
information that was being sort of fed
into the fed into the into the rat or
mouse in this case the second study we
did was on the hippocampus region of
similar mice where they were in a maze
and the question was could you recover
the structure of the maze just purely
from the basis of the signals that you
know from the spikes that you are
collecting from their brains and it
turns out that again you couldn't
construct the details of a maze but you
could construct the topology of the maze
so for example if the means had a hole
in the middle you could recover it very
easily but getting it so for example
getting a corner was next to impossible
because again topology doesn't see
corners but the structure of what what
somebody went through was topological
represented in their brains and we could
recover those signals from the from the
data we collected from their brains so
it's somewhat related and yeah yeah I
love that question also I had another
thought that popped into my head while
you were talking is we when you were
talking about the the an instance of bad
data and bad data is obviously it's
garbage in garbage out right and and so
off and it is that risk that you don't
know what that your input is bad and so
forth so something is a different sort
of kind of human comparison that came to
mind is are these models being built in
a way with a kind of self reflective
capacity or a self a capacity that's
sort of going is analyzing I don't know
that's looking for you know in what ways
are they looking for bad data or looking
for other essentially kind of biases or
protecting us against biases that we may
be prone to doing it how and maybe just
in general in terms of its own or the
risk of a built in i coded in bias it as
if you will and and as well as the human
bias biases of those who are reading it
after the fact yeah
so generally it is somewhat technically
possible to do it today mm-hmm
and what would you call that well how
would you how would you better character
act but I just yeah
mumbled there so so let's say that you
are building a mortgage model that's a
very simple example everybody
understands right so if you're building
a mortgage model to figure out whether
to approve somebody is mortgage or not
that right so essentially that's that's
analyzing someone who's applied for a
mortgage that's okay that's good
now oftentimes the way those models are
built today is that a bank or a lender
would look at their data across the
history look at the decisions that their
lenders made right and then try to mimic
that now the question is if the lender
made a mistake what do you do about it
is that bad data it's not malformed yeah
it's collected and it's sort of
represented in the correct way but it's
well documented there have been horrible
things that have been have that's right
if the lender history of banks yes so
the question is that is a kind of bad
data problem that you can actually
completely solve today interesting that
is the kind of bad data problem where
you can throw it into such an analysis
and you can figure out what are the
areas where the model is making
systematic errors what are the biases
what is the structure of the data
overall and what is the structure of the
decisions overall that's that's the kind
of error that you can eliminate there is
another kind of error in the bad data
category which is really hard which is
now imagine that this is the same Bank
right let's say they were operating in
Singapore and all of a sudden they make
a decision to go start operating in
India right they have great data in
Singapore and create social economic
structures in India they're very
different so when you when you start
applying a similar logic to a completely
different ecosystem yeah it won't work
anymore so now you have data that's
again well structured and well collected
and well formed but it's useless mm-hmm
and that is slightly harder because it's
also cold start rolling okay what do you
but where are the first level does it
tell
useless is there something in the in in
the algorithm or even just the process
of using it that that helps you to
understand you've got a problem here
that's because that's that's one of the
other questions is how can it in a way
it's it's kind of drawing a circle to
say there's something over here and it
may be something very profitable very
useful that's over here but it could
also be we have a problem in Sector
seven and and and what do we do about it
so how is our are these technologies or
is this yeah it was this framework good
at signaling us for those kinds of hey
human it was a different kind of look at
this apply attention over here it can do
it in a well running system already so
you know one in a well running system
well right know for example if you've
been doing it in let's say Singapore
again as an example and you've been
doing it and you've been collecting data
for how it did then the model can start
suggesting that even though I am trying
my best to emulate what a human lender
did but here's what I'm seeing in my
error surface yeah and here's what I
suggest you change yeah that is possible
yeah but if you are in a de novo
situation where you don't have any data
right so you're saying it's got a base
life it's got a base line now it's got
something to see that bear that's how
interesting but the interesting thing
about the base line is that it's an
engineering problem now in many cases we
can actually engineer the system so that
it has and creates a baseline and
operates off of that and taking that
engineering approach to these systems is
actually I believe will be a huge bang
for the buck in general in the economy
if we applied it we have another
question on the second draft thank you
very much for this wonderful talk and
the question that I have is about
scientific methods of analysis through
the history so there was the age of
proof mathematical and logical and
there's the age of modeling with
calculus and you know all the
descendants of it and then there is the
age of like ultimate pattern recognition
by the Machine so how do these connect
for example what's the role of something
like a stochastic simulation or
continuously relation in this world
so that was a really great question I
make sure yeah thank you yep that was a
really good question I so I think if I
can let me summarize the question just
so we are on the same page and then then
I can answer it if I'm correct so the
question was you know we've had many
ways of inquiry we've had sort of prove
it to me you know write an algebraic
proof they've had you know here's the
you know here's the here's the data and
here's the equation and now does it work
or not right and the question was what
what what do we or how do we deal with
stochastic systems where we are
simulating and we are collecting data
right okay so so I believe that we do
stochastic simulations in areas where
it's too expensive to do real
simulations right either they are too
time-consuming or they're too resource
intensive or they won't finish or it's
simply infeasible in the sense that
there is just way too many variables
right and oftentimes when we code these
stochastic simulations in a lot of
stochastic simulations what ends up
happening is that you find the structure
that you code it in to it right so for
example if you made an assumption
implicitly explicit assumptions are
easier you can write them down but if
you made an implicit assumption in a
stochastic simulation discovering those
becomes a very huge challenge and in
many cases those implicit assumptions
are not desirable so this is something
that happens in economic models all the
time where we make stochastic economic
predictions and stock markets do this a
whole lot market makers of all sort do
like Blackrock they all do this and in
many of these cases the implicit
assumptions really get you because
especially you said okay so the interest
rate is going to go up fine that's fine
you've written it down but you know you
never wrote down the fact or other
implicitly it was the case in your model
that whenever interest rate went down
your you know your economy grew right so
for example that stochastic simulation
that might be an implicit assumption but
that's not true in today's kuku days so
how would you discovering those kinds of
implicit assumptions is where this would
be important
right back here uh so I'm gonna ask you
to make a subjective assessment of the
world here I was very intrigued by your
example with the bridges that people had
a hard time figuring this thing out and
we're doing things like measuring the
lengths of the bridges and I mean like I
mean how struggling to find out what
kind of calculation they were trying to
do you know when the example that's
given is like what I was why I was
already thinking my head and I've
already absorbed the wisdom of this of
the mathematician but it this problem of
people paying a lot of attention to
things that are wrong or having like
really dumb theories that aren't even
related to the problem they're trying to
solve I mean don't we still have that in
this world so my question is I get the
thrust of your talk that we have some
tools to kind of get around this problem
but are we also swamped by people
looking at the wrong information and
paying attention to things that don't
matter and and and if you were to give
an assessment of the world in terms of
whether we're paying more attention to
those things versus better approaches
I'm curious if there are examples that
come to your mind or or what you would
say about that that bigger question so I
think generally it's an untenable
question over all right are people
focusing on the right things or not the
word right is yeah yeah that's right
so for example in the case of the city
you know the right was a verifiable
answer you can verify whether you've
crossed all the bridges once or not and
so on but in many of our real life
problems right is sort of undefined that
said though I think there is reason to
be optimistic right which is when we
look at for example all of the
scientific data which is sort of where
all this research originated then you
know to a large degree we actually do
have tools today that allow you to you
know take in large amounts of data and
then focus in on interesting parts it is
for the domain expert to decide whether
they're the right parts or not and
whether they fit in with their
contextual knowledge but at least it
will focus you on the interesting parts
of the data that have some coherent
structure to them but I think at the end
of the day I don't think this is
the problem will ever solve over all and
we we should hope not
right it would kind of make make it
useless to exist you know like some
level off versus you know since we are
here and I see all these science-fiction
books around here
there was novel by arthur c clarke you
know in which there is a perfect society
and everything is great and everybody
does the same you know and so on and so
forth but the people who program the
perfect society or thank you
the people who prefer to program the
perfect society also programmed a joker
in the society who every now and then
would just come in and drag havoc you
know [ __ ] would hit the ceiling and you
know eventually at the end of the book
you discover that they did this they
allowed this joker system to exist in
the novel or in the in that society just
to keep things interesting otherwise it
would be too programmatic you know so
like in some sense you kind of hope for
some whimsy right so so in some sense
some of it i don't it's fine some of it
should exist but for many other
interesting scientific questions we
actually do have good solutions today so
if you don't ask you this question
because you have this interesting
background and you've cut across a few
different worlds that that i unique
perspective in that which is you have a
math PhD you have the the computer
science but you've also been an
entrepreneur in this frothy silicon
valley and in this moment when terms
like artificial intelligence and big
data the kind of marketing terms or
things that we all know about but what
actually they mean is is they're they're
rather representing pretty broad things
that you're dealing with the actual let
alone you know the the math and and
theory even even behind that to a
certain extent so I'm curious for your
your thought about and I guess I think
about it in three ways that there's the
you know the business is doing what it's
doing and its communicating in certain
ways to tell businesses that something
like you know machine learning and
artificial intelligence are useful for
their business we've already
talked about the fact that one of the
things topological data analysis does is
it it makes some of these the benefits
of this technology accessible when you
don't have the data scientist at a
certain level on staff and so in a way
it's democratizing and spreading some of
these capabilities around but at the
same time there's this this hype machine
and there is if there's a blur on it and
then and then a third way in addition to
the people that might be shopping for
this technology and the people that are
producing this technology the third is
kind of the general public a lot of us
are in where we may not be laying our
hands on this but we're getting a sense
of and we may have more common sense of
what AI means or whatever so I'm curious
what with with the the perspective again
that you have having gone through kind
of a bunch of different layers of this
you know where what is what is fact and
what is fiction here where how how
mature is this technology and also again
seeking maybe just the broadest audience
as well as to to folks that are more
closer to this tech today in this
audience you know what should we know to
make sense of of what this moment is and
what the real benefits are of some of
these things yeah so there's a lot there
yeah yeah I so I love things I think you
started kind of with the with the arc of
my career yeah I think in general math
and computer science even though they
kind of work together have generally
been at odds with each other in the
sense that the area of math somehow has
gotten into a state culturally where
people who are mathematicians want to do
pure math things they want to stand in
front of blackboards and write which
show up that's I kid you not the not the
biggest most heated debates that we had
at Stanford in the math department was
when they replace the blackboard with
the whiteboards and thankfully they've
gone back which is the right call
they're black now that's watch out for
automation so so but but you know in
general
in math math is kind of gone off in a
bit of a tangent we're generally
culturally it's almost fitting but yeah
but but I think generally speaking
computer scientists distrust
mathematicians to a degree in the sense
that because they have to get over a lot
of mumbo-jumbo that they don't
understand yeah and mathematicians
generally don't want to quote-unquote
stoop low to communicate their ideas and
in a more effective way so I think
generally speaking there is a lot there
is a lot in math which was discovered
hundreds of years ago which is actually
SuperDuper relevant which you know which
I I hope that feels come together in a
more coherent way and and sort of
benefit each other I think there's a lot
like had we not done the number theory
we would not have had Bitcoin you could
argue about its value I like it but you
could argue about it but it will not
have you not have had it had we not have
research number theory and cryptographic
systems mm-hmm
so I think generally these two fields
need to come together in a more coherent
way and then they are today now the
second part was to sort of think about
what is what is the hype and what is the
reality and I I think generally the sad
fact in 2019 is the bar to call
something AI is very low yeah like you
can have an Excel spreadsheet with a few
formulas and got a gold star
[Music]
don't try and run a spaceship with it so
like in general whenever somebody says
you know blind
telogen sore blind elegent or whatever
it's not it's not it just isn't in fact
I think we should stop using the word
intelligence in the context of machine
learning because it is an
anthropomorphic idea which sort of leads
to pointless debates and quantification
you know which is useless to people so I
I think we should try and divorce
ourselves from the idea of intelligence
because we have no idea we have no idea
we have what we have built thus far to
our credit and to the credit of
everybody in this area is we built
narrow
systems that are very good at solving
specific problems very well and with
high repeatability but in no way shape
or form are these systems anywhere close
to being intelligent in a way that your
I would call them intelligent so that
that's what I would say about marketing
versus basically the one question you
need to ask is do you have software
behind this or are you doing it in Excel
you know like nothing bad about the
Excel people they are good people but
that's not it's not AI nothing isn't
overall is my view and we are a long
ways away from it there's a lot we need
to know and study okay all right well I
think we're going to leave there were a
little bit over time you're gonna stick
around yep I have a dart and there are
some neat animations that are running up
back there well who who warned some more
technical geekery I'm happy to oblige
yeah so your sheets gonna stay here we'd
love for you to stay come up he's happy
to chat with you I know I know a bunch
of you had questions we didn't get to
but thank you so much for being a great
audience kerchief with a big round of
applause for Jean
[Applause]
[Music]